In 1907, the American economy experienced a great state of
panic and financial awe that galvanized people to banks
to withdraw their deposits. The main reason that ignited the crisis was a failed attempt by a group of speculators
to acquire shares of the United Copper Company in order to manipulate prices.
At that time, the United States was the main financial power Who did not have a central bank.
However, After the severe economic turmoil caused by this financial chaos,
such as the inability of banks to return depositors' money and the bankruptcy of many American companies;
There were calls for the need to establish a financial institution to prevent such panic and turmoil.
Then, 6 years later, specifically on December 23, 1913,
US President Woodrow Wilson signed the Federal Reserve Act
to establish the Federal Reserve or the American Central Bank.
Over time, the US Federal Reserve, 109 years old, became the most dangerous and influential financial institution in the whole world.
The role of the Federal Reserve is to achieve two main goals,
which are often referred to as the Dual Mandate.
The first goal is to direct the US economy towards maximum sustainable employment.
The second goal: is to maintain price stability or control inflation levels
any economy has a specific imposed speed just like the speed of the car, so that it does not run persistently above or below its imposed rate
Otherwise, there will be many economic problems such as inflation, deflation, unemployment...etc.
When the American economy grows too quickly or too slowly,
the US Federal Reserve intervenes to adjust the speed through the monetary policy
that it is responsible for managing it economically.
One of the courses that can carry out this task is interest rates.
Although they are all internal decisions concerning the American economy,
their impact transcends American borders and goes beyond the United States to all global markets,
and affects the living standards of individuals in developing and emerging countries specifically like the economies of Arab countries.
That is why it is necessary for us as Arabs to understand the impact of the Federal Reserve’s decisions and their long term consequences.
The global influence of the American Federal Reserve is of course due to the fact that the American economy is the largest in the world.
The American dollar is the dominant currency in the global economy.
We have even seen over the course of the previous six weeks the power of the cosmopolitan American economics
over the Russian economy after the Russian war on Ukraine.
As known, the US Federal Reserve raised interest rates on Wednesday, March 16th.
Here a main question arises: What is the impact of such a dangerous decision on the Arab countries?
Moreover, we need to know why the Fed raised the interest rate, and what is this institution’s function in the American economy?
Yet, before digging in, don't forget to subscribe to the channel to see all our episodes.
I am Ashraf Ibrahim and this is the economic informant
I just want to say in the first place that this episode is sponsored by ‘Mostaqel’ company
It is the largest platform for Arab freelance work.. Through Mostaqel , you can hire the best Arab freelancers remotely.
You can also hire a programmer to build a website or a mobile app,
hire designers to design a logo for your project, writers, translators, marketers and others..
I personally use Mostaqel when I need any of those.. To know more about Mostaqel; check the link down below in the video description
Last January, the inflation rate in the United States
reached a new record level of 7.9%,
which is the highest and fastest rate of inflation in America in 40 years,
specifically from February 1982,
when the inflation rate at that time reached 7.6%
It is assumed that the target inflation rate will be Between 1% - 2% only.
This means that there is a major imbalance in the American economy,
and here comes the role of the US Federal Reserve, which can address this imbalance through interest rates.
On Wednesday evening, the US Federal Reserve raised interest rates by a quarter of a percentage point by 0.25%,
that is the first time the Fed raises interest rates in 4 years, in December 2018.
This increase was actually what we expected in March in the episode of the 2022 economic forecasts.
It was published last month, and it will give you a clear view of many things that will most likely happen,
You can see it from here
The Fed will not stop at this increase only, officials expect that interest rates will reach 1.75% by the end of the current year 2022.
This means that there are about 6 more increases in the way,
assuming that the Fed will move in quarter-point increments as it did two days ago.
There are expectations that the increase in interest rates will continue in 2023 as well.
Here, of course, a crucial question arises: What is the effect of raising US interest rates on us here in the Arab world?
Of course, the effect will be different from one country to another, according to a lot of data related to each economy alone
In summary, we can clarify some of the effects as follows
The most direct impact that will affect each and every arabic monetary system is the expected raise in the dollar exchange rate, in comparison with Arab currencies,
specifically those of countries that allow an exchange rate with a type of flexibility.
That is why we find that most Arab central banks are also raising interest rates after the US Federal decision,
in order to reduce financial burdens on its currency and markets.
The financial burden of these economies will even get more complicated if they are suffering several dollar debts.
The depreciation of its local currency against the dollar will mount its obligations,
in other words, they will be vulnerable to default on its debts.
Even when these countries resort to foreign external borrowing, the cost will be high,
so, this will make their chances of getting a loan pretty difficult. Otherwise, they must raise interest rates to higher levels in order to be able to attract creditors,
and in the end this increases their debt levels. So, the question is: what is the volume of Arab countries debt?
In a recent study, the United Nations Economic and Social Commission for Western Asia (ESCWA),
last October 2021, it warned of the unprecedented increase in the public debt in the Arab countries,
and that it reached 1.4 trillion dollars in 2020,
which represents about 60% of the gross domestic product of the Arab region.
Another concern related to the Fed's raising of the interest rate is the exit of foreign investments in debt instruments in the Arab markets
As a result of the Federal Reserve raising interest rates,
the US market becomes more attractive to international investors
Thus investors layover their business in the developing and emerging markets that experience many risks
to flee to the US market lusting for the high interest rate with very few risks.
This creates heavy financial burdens on the markets of countries that depend on foreign currencies,
as they will just go away with the slightest changes in profit rates, leaving a gap that can not be ridged in these economies.
The decline in the value of local currencies against the dollar, the high cost of borrowing from abroad and the exit of foreign capital,
will lead to an increase in the deficit of local budgets, consequently, social spending and support programs will be reduced.
This will lead to a decline in economic growth, an increase in unemployment rates and a deterioration in living standards.
Another hazardous effect of raising US interest rates and consequently the depreciation of the local currency against the dollar is: imported inflation.
This happens to countries that have a large deficit in the trade balance.
they import more than they export this drives an increase in the cost of imports.
On the other hand, the rate of the local currency decreases against the dollar will be a strong point in the export-dependent economies
because their exports will be cheaper in international markets and this is a competitive advantage that gives away to them to enter new markets.
Raising interest rates in the United States will lead to a decline in the prices of gold all over the world.
The reason is that investors who used to protect their investments by buying and keeping gold
(especially in this troubled time that the world is going through after the Russian Ukrainian war),
will begin to change their minds and dispense with gold to invest in US Treasury bonds as their benefit from the rise in interest rates,
whether at the current level or the upcoming rises in interest rates, and this leads to an increase in the supply of gold in the world and thus a decrease in its price.
The same negative effect will reach oil prices, although there are many factors involved in the oil price equation,
such as Western sanctions on one of the largest oil producers in the world: Russia.
Taking in consideration other factors that are being stabilized, raising interest rates in the United States leads to an increase in the dollar exchange rate.
The dollar is the main currency used in oil trading, and this makes crude oil and petroleum products more expensive for
consumers who use other currencies, thus, affects the global demand for oil and its price drops may drop by time.
However, as I said a while ago, there are many factors that control oil prices in particular other than The US Federal Reserve raising the interest rate,
so cautions must be taken. In the end, we can generally say, that the effect of the Federal Reserve raising interest rates
will be negative on developing and emerging economies such as the Arab economies,
and the only way for our Arab countries out of this crisis is through strengthening the foundations of their economies at all levels,
in addition to reducing imports in exchange for focusing on the export-based economic model.
As for individuals (or what we can do in such period of time), there is an upcoming episode in which we will focus on how we can act as individuals currently.
That's why you need to subscribe to the channel and activate the bell to see the episode as soon as it is uploaded.
What is the most pivotal thing that the Arab countries can do
to reduce the impact of the Fed raising interest rates,
especially with the continuation of the policy of raising interest rates in 2022 and 2023 as well?
I will follow up all your answers in the comments.
I hope you like the episode, like and share and subscribe to the channel, if you please, to see all our episodes, tell your friends about us, they may like it too, Goodbye.